are going to be judges tell us about one
Activity one main functions and symmetry
of information
this is a joint work with uh
rahu yango
um
and this work is about the connection
between two things so one is the one-way
functions I guess it is one of the most
important objects in quick programming
and the other is called the symmetry of
information which is an important
property of comical complexity and it is
something that uh we don't have a very
good understanding in the time boundary
setting
and the main results of this work is a
new characterization of one-way
functions using um time boundary
simulation of information
and we show that one-way function XX if
when only if some average version of
time balance image of information fails
uh I will talk more about this uh in the
rest of this talk
I guess um I've seen uh common golf
complexity many times in previous talks
so let me just look at the definition
very quickly
so for binary string x uh we're going to
load the length of the shortest string
from which we can recover X
so the comic book of capacity of X is
then defined as the minimum length of
string M which is called a program
so such that if we fit the end to the
universal training machines we get X
and we can also Define the conditional
variant where we are given an additional
string that helps to recover X so the
comic of convection of x given Y is the
minimum length of a program that recover
X using the string Y
and uh yeah we can also Define a
time-mounted version of uh combo
time-bounded version of complexity so in
this case we fix a time-bound function t
for assemble T is a polynomial
and the T time-bounded comic of capacity
uh denoted by K superscript T is the
minimum length of a program that can uh
recover the string within t stats
and as I've seen in uh some of the
previous talks so time management of
capacity is very useful and recently has
many exciting applications in complex
Theory and cryptography and also
learning
as I mentioned earlier the focus of this
talk is something called a symmetry of
information which is an important
properties of common golf complexity
so uh let me tell you what it is
so first of all um if we have a two
string X and Y
then it's it is easy to select the comic
of capacity of X and Y is at most The
Chronic of empty of X plus the core
compressed of Y comma X and this is just
because if we have a
if we have a program that brings X and
we have a program that brings y given X
then we can combine them to get a
program that prints uh both X and Y
and so much of information
in the time and Boundary setting
basically says that this uh inequality
is tight in the sense that the
Chromebook of capacity of X and Y is at
least The Chronic of capacity of
X plus the Chromebook of capacity of Y
given x minus some uh small turn
and now if we combine the two inequality
um above
then we get
and we get something looks like this uh
which is analogous to what is also
called a symmetry of information in
Charlotte's information Theory
and sometimes people uh people call this
the Chang Wu but we'll just call it a
symmetry of information
yeah we have so much information for
Time unbounded comic of conversity so
the question is whether symmetry of
information holds in the time-bounder
setting
so for example can we show that
the KT complexity of X and Y is at least
the K policy capacity of X plus the K
quality capacitive y given X minus some
other log turn
and then here we uh we're allowed to
have uh
up along the overhead in the time bounds
on the right hand side so so this makes
the right hand side uh smaller
and it turns out that the time
management of information is unlikely to
hold so um there's a work by long plat
and watanabad so they show that if
one-way functions accepts
then we don't have signature of
information for KT
and the proof requires a little bit of
work but the intuition is uh very simple
so so let's consider one-way permutation
for Simplicity so if we have um like one
weapon mutation f
and q and x we can compute f of x
efficiency a given f of x we cannot get
back efficiently so although these two
string contains all the information
um about each other but there's a
there's an asymmetry between then When
taking into account the time
this intuition
um
why if one way function X6 then low
symmetry of information for KT
and but this results only shows one
directions and we don't know if the
value of
and we don't know if the value of
summation time balancing motion of
information uh implies the resistance
for one-way functions
and it was an open question to show some
uh if and only if statement between
one-way functions and
uh symmetry of information
can you sketch how symmetry symmetry of
information is proved in the unbounded
setting
oh yeah yeah I I I uh I cannot record
the details but it involves some
exhaustic search so it usually lies on
the compounded feature of Commonwealth
University so it you cannot extend it in
the uh to the time bound case
okay let's go step back and review the
definition of one-way functions to see
um what might be the issues to uh
uh to establishing an equivalent between
one-way function then simulation of
information
so usually when talking about one way
function we just say that our function
is one way if it is easy to compute and
hard to invert
but in a more formal definitions
it's just uh it's just a step it's hard
to inward for
almost all inputs
a lot heavy inputs
and it has to be had against
probabilistic adversaries
these are two important
details in the definition of one-way
functions
and then using the intuition that I just
mentioned so this these two leads us to
think maybe we need to adjust the
statement of symmetry of invasion
in order to get influence
and for example instead of constrained
whether um
uh whether a symmetry information host
for every pair of strings maybe we
should consider average pairs
so um so to reflect uh this fact and
also uh maybe you should consider some
probabilistic version of time boundary
comic book of MST
um to address the fact that the
different uh the definition of long wave
function in the definition of one-way
function even trying to recover a
pre-image using a proper State algorithm
it's not possible
okay allow this needs me to talk about
some
um
progress Solutions of time bounded
combat of capacity so one such lotion is
called the randomized T time bounded
chronic of capacity
so remember
um
the KT definition the KT complexity of a
string is the minimum length of a
program that prints the string
deterministically in t stats
and then here
um
the rkt capacity of a string is the
minimum length of a randomized program
that brings the strength with
probability at least two thirds
so there so um there's a fixed fixed
program a randomized one that outputs
the strength with high probability over
its internal Randomness so this is a rkt
and a lot of slightly more
more complicated lotion is called
probabilistic T time monochrome of
capacity
or pkt
so um
okay the pkt capacity of a string X is
defined as the minimum K such that with
probability at least two-thirds over a
random string W there's a program m
that takes WS input and brings X
so unlike in the previous cases where we
have a fixed program that prints X so
either a deterministic one or randomized
one here we say that for most random
strings there is a program that brings X
and the random and the program can
depends on the random string
so in this case it's like a
probabilistic encoding of X where the
encoding depends on the randomness and
instead of a fixed encoding
now let me State our results uh more
formally
um we show that
um
access
if when uh if when only
if only if average case image of
information for PK polyhose
so
so average case symmetry of information
for application means for every
polynomial time sample of the
distribution T over 2 Amp bits
and for every sufficiently large T that
is greater than some polynomial there
are Infinity many ends such that with
high probability over a pair of strings
X and Y
such that a single shot of information
holds for X and Y
respect to uh pkt so in other words the
picket can be duplicate capacitive as X
and Y is
greater than the PKD of
capacitor of X Plus duplicity of
capacity of Y gamma x minus some order
log turn
so this is a average case image of
information for pkt
and you may notice that in this case we
only say that
uh
average case simulation formation hole
for Infinity many n and this is actually
expected because
if one-way function do not exists it
means we can invert any function on
Infinity many inputs
so in 2T we should have only we only
have time balance symmetry between
the image and image on both input
lengths so this only um
Infinity offense if we can break one-way
functions Infinity often
but our result is like also robust in
terms of this
so if we instead say the infinity open
one-way function to log X6 then we have
that the average case image of
information hold almost everywhere
um so in the previous result uh
we use PK pkt
uh to capture one-way functions or or
the long assessments of one-way
functions and it turns out that we can
also use rkt but in this case we have to
move to the
what's the polynomial time we're doing
so um we show that the cost of
polynomial time secured one-way
functions do not access if and only if
average case symmetry of information for
RK quasi polyhose
so here everything is uh the sentence
before except that t has to be greater
than some quasi poly and and we are
talking about um one-way function that
is secured against
um
possible normal time uh adversaries
yes
and correspondingly
and by the way uh we are talking about
one-way function that's still require
efficiently compatible but if security
is against uh qualified number time
now let's look at the pool and we focus
on the PKD case first
so uh we want to show that um Infinity
open uh only function to log X6 is
equivalent to average case signature of
information for PK polyhose
and what we are going to show is that
these are both equivalent to something
called the average case conditional
coding
and I will explain uh what it is but
before telling you what conditional
coding is I need to tell you about the
original coding theorem
um in common ground capacity
so just like symmetry of information the
coding feeling is another
um important property of Chromebook of
capacity
so it says that if we have a computable
distribution B that samples the string x
with probability D of x
then the comic of capacitor of X is at
most one lower T of x
so if a string is uh sample above then
we can encode it
in short length
again this is for this is for Time
unbounded comic of capacity and we don't
have such a cooling clearance for K
party
so even if we just consider efficiently
sample report distribution we don't have
a coding theorem for just keyboarding
foreign
if we consider pkt then we do have a
coding theorem so uh with Oliveira and
Siemens we show that if if we have a
point number time sample distribution
that samples are string x with
probability of X then the PK poly
capacity of X is at most log
1 over T of X and plus some all the log
n terms
so this is the optimal coding clearance
for PK poly
okay another useful fact related to this
is that for any distribution d
the Chromebook of capacity at the time
and volume one the common core of
capacity
is greater than
uh is at least the log
of 1 over
the probability of X like with high
probability
uh or X sampled from d
so this is that
the time the K capacity is at least this
quality
and below that the PK poly capacity is
at least uh the K capacity like roughly
so by coding we have that this is uh and
most days and by this fact we say that
most for most strength PK quality should
be greater than this and then color is
just says that the PK quality of X is
roughly equal to the log 1 over the
probability of x
with five probability when X sampled
from d
so on average this so on average these
two quantities are the same
what is a conditional coding so
conditional coding says that for every
polynomial distribution T which allows
is on two end bits so examples appear
and for every pair X and Y in the
support of d
the PK poly contest of x given y is at
most log 1 over the probability of X
conditioning on y
and we call it a conditional coding
because here we are we want to relay the
pkt capacitor of x given y
to the probability of X or conditioning
on y
so that's a conditional coding
and again we can Define the average
version by saying that the conditional
coding holds for
X and Y with high probability when X Y
the sample from the same distributility
yeah
Foundation yeah I really don't have it
is
the statement definition so this is
definition oh okay
uh conditioning
coding means this thing
so it's a lot of theorem maybe don't
think that this is true yeah so
conditional coding holds when this is
true yeah yeah this means conditions
available
depression yeah
and this same worst case so for every X
and Y in the support we say that the PKD
Progressive explain wise and most clock
101 the probability of X conditioning
online and this is the average case
where we consider
distribution
yeah so this D is also this the um
so this is over two end bits so examples
X and Y
EP now I get new y
what's the probability of Sling s
conditioning on that you're saying y
okay so this conditional coding
or hjs I just claimed the earlier
average conditional coding is equivalent
to
um
okay this condition over the car
okay as I click uh earlier so
one wave function to law access
different only if average penis folding
holes that means if one-way function is
six
and every then condition holding should
not hold
so even though we have uh coding for
original coding but we probably don't
have a conditional code name and you'll
be wondering why we cannot use the
original coding fear into shoulder
conditional volume
and this this is because the conditional
putting fear and
this one mechanical inference can be
building as we are trying to encode
string eggs we are X is a sample from
some conditional distribution
e that's that's conditional on
assumption y so even though the joint
distribution of t is polynomial time
sampling
but the conditional probability
distribution May lock before number five
example when you're conditional on
sunstring so we cannot apply the
original coding theorem to this
conditional distribution because the
original cooling failure only was for
polynomial time sample per distributions
foreign
[Music]
okay one is stronger than the other so
leader of this one so if normally want
to say excess even on average you should
don't have conditional volume so if you
don't have it on average
you don't have rate in the more space
okay as I cleaned the earlier the
average average case conditional coding
is damage case conditioning is
equivalent to every case symmetry of
formations so let me show you the proof
of this so it's very simple
so let's fix the polynomial distribution
T the sample Supply X and Y
so on the top we have uh average case
conditional coding and we want to get
average case symmetry of information on
at the bottom
now uh now first of all let's remove the
probability and just keep in mind that
we are dealing with an average pair X
and Y sample from d
and we then identify the common quantity
in both Expressions which is PK poly of
x given y
and then we just like we we haven't
changed a little bit to make them uh
more alike so nothing happened yet at
this point
now on the top we have a probability of
X conditioning on y
and we can provide it as the ratio
between the
The Joint probability of X and Y and the
marginal probability of Y so here D to
the two delos the marginal distribution
the lowest marginal distribution of Y on
the second half
so this conditional and just the joint
distribution and the marginal
distribution
and now we have uh got rid of the
conditional probability
so let's rear interesting uh a little
bit further so allow the bottom two
lines looks
like kind of similar
and remember what I said earlier so one
once we have conditional coding like the
original one for PK poly we can say that
for any polynomial time sample
distribution the PK poly capacitor of a
string is roughly equal to the log of 1
over the probability of the string with
high probability
which is here
so this means these two things and here
because both D and the marginal
distribution of D are polynomial
sampling
so by the coding we actually have that
these two quantity should be about the
same and these two quantity are also
about the same at least on average
so basically this completes the proof
because we can just replace this one
with this one and this one and with this
one and this is the
image of information
and this shows the fourth Direction but
the proof of the other direction is
exactly the same we can just reverse the
previous argument
and we won't get into the details
so now we have shown um average case
conditional coding is equivalent to
average case symmetry of informations so
it remains to show the equation between
the long existence of one wave function
an average case conditional coding
and we're going to do uh One Direction
then let me try to give some high level
distribution of the proof of the four
directions
so assume that we can involve one-way
function like almost everywhere
we want to show that high probability
over a pair X and Y sampled for
distribution D then conditional coding
holds for X and Y which means what is
written here
and remember earlier we talked about
using the original coding theorem for PK
party to show a conditional coding
experience
and the reason why it didn't work was
that the coding variant can only be
applied to efficient efficiently
sampleable distribution
but here we are dealing with the
conditional
probability distribution of D
conditioning on some string y
and then the conditional distribution
may not be pronounced by sample even
though T itself even though D itself is
quantum sampling
a lot of things are a little bit
different because we can invert Runway
functions
so with this assumption we can hold to
sample the conditional distribution
efficiency
and in the in the work by uh implasso
and Ruby and by uh impression so they
show that they showed something called
an extrapolator under the assumption
that one-way function is not accept
so if Infinity often wave function do
not exist therefore every polynomial
test and probability distribution T
which again samples appear X and Y
and there's a efficient randomized
algorithm that given y that
approximately samples the distribution
the conditioning on y for almost all y
so I actually don't understand why you
need the number 11 not just the paper
with movie
because when I when I was looking for
like this film they usually cycle but I
actually I can't even I had a hard time
finding a truth but of this thing but
eventually I found it in Russell's
synthesis so I'm not sure which one is
the correct salvation
impossible
with uh there was a six-page
box
was a limited Fox
that's 1.86 painted
explain me too sweetly yeah
yeah but I uh there's a proof available
in uh
you probably also want to read like
books what he writes about my driving
it's all true
but I didn't write it
okay so this
so this basically it says that if I said
we can efficiently sample the
conditional distribution
and this approximately
at least foremost why
so basically that's
what we need in order to uh apply the
original coding theorem to get
conditional coding
so we basically use the efficient
extrapolator as a proxy for the
conditional distribution and because
it's efficient we can just apply the
coding theorem to it
and with a little bit more work we can
show that this gives the average case
conditional coding
um that we wanted like
okay as I mentioned we also showed an
equivalent between the long existence of
one-way function and the average case
image of information but for PK sorry
for for rkt RK quality
uh
proof that I just described use the
original coding theorem for pkt but we
don't have a coding theorem for rkt
so actually for this one we need to use
a different approach
and I will lock uh talk about the detail
but the starting point is the reason to
result by Elan golden and Santana
so they show that if one-way function do
not X6 then there's a heuristic for
approximating the K capacity
and like we have seen in some of the
previous talks we can use such a
heuristic as some kind of a
distinguisher and combine it with
certain generator that has an rkt style
reconstruction property
uh that have a reconstruction procedure
and this will allow us to show that
rkt capacity and the K capacity are very
close on average
so these two are very close on average
now then we can just take this image of
information theorem for time and
Boundary case complexity and replace K
with rkt
and then this will give us an average
case symmetry of information for RK
for rkt
and actually we did the conditional
variance of these measures but we will
not get into the details
but one reason that we only get the
quality polynomial time is because
the generator that we use here has some
like poly log overhead in terms of the
advice complexity so we can lock so we
can only show that like rkt and kie core
up to some poly lock
additive turns
so with in this case we don't get the
optimal
symmetry of information for rkt
so that's why we
need to go to the
corresponding time routine
okay finally I want to mention some
other results that we have in our paper
so I just show you in this talk that we
can characterize the long existence of
one-way functions using average case
conditional coding and average case
image of information
but in the paper we also show that they
are equivalent to something called
the average case conditional language
compression which is which is some
version of the language compression
theorem
uh the income of capacity so language
compression is another like important
property of
comic of capacity
so this for
uh
well
the case uh where among function draw
exists and we can also characterize some
MPS contained in BPP using this case
worst case conditional coding and
language compression
and similar similarly for MPS easy on
average
we can characterize it using another
kind of average case version of the same
property called independent average case
but I guess I will not Define it here
but but the idea is that this gives a
way to look at this uh
standard complexity assumption through
the lens of com golf capacity and its
properties
yeah we do have some version like
yeah but but it's a little bit hard to
uh explain that version It's called The
certifiable version
yeah we can talk more about it
one thing that you may notice is that um
we only have symmetry Automation in the
we only have symmetry of information in
the one-way function case and we don't
have it in the other two case so this is
an exceptional case
where we can use symmetry of information
to characterize it
and so and um oh that's another question
oh okay
maybe yeah
oh yeah yeah
for example
we don't know whether what case social
formation
we don't know what whether we can use
most cases which equipment to capture
MPS in PPP and we only know that empty
is the dtp in price the price worst case
switch of information and in fact
assuming MPS average KCC airless suffice
to give you worst case SOI
so then the interesting question is what
can
what can worst case symmetry information
care twice now it's just sandwich
between sandwich between MP is average
KCC and low one-way function but we
don't know what it can like characterize
exactly
I think this
foreign
so that's worst case symmetry of
information for pkp
yeah and in this case anything is uh
stayed which is back to the pkt okay
so
so we know under a derandomization
hypothesis
pkt and KT are roughly the same
and we know that in the worst case
symmetry of information provably does
not hold for KT
so is there a
uh
when you say it must pay so much whims
and passenger for KT right you know
talking about lemons notion of KT
so um no that's right yeah yeah right
it's the other one so you don't know how
to do any of this for
PK superscript t
um
so the probabilistic equations yeah that
lotion has stopped being investigated
much
fresh but at least that of this course
for Peak a little T
if you define the notion of picadot
but still that doesn't give you any
unintentional result because we don't
know how do we feel so much of
information for PK Little T uh so the
only result
um the only the only thing that we load
is we can refute worst case symmetry of
information for lemons KB to T that's
the only result let me know about 10
minus symbol change simulation
unconditionally
so I assume every time you're talking
about one-way functions here you're
talking about one of my functions secure
gets uniform polynomial time adversaries
is there a natural way to translate this
for a non-uniform uh one of my functions
like maybe like P polycentrics
oh you miss yeah yeah
when you say average case and then you
talk about wave function
the
the distribution corresponds to
the one-way function but the error
survey corresponds to the lotion of
homework of capacity so when I say the
longer functions secured against
large uniform essays you need to change
the comic of conveston ocean and I
believe
we have talked about this now with micro
office
big time uh somehow characterized and
using
some conditional version of symmetrical
confirmation which may not be easy to
stay
maybe it's possible yes
questions
thank you